to pick six or eight what would you pick
for yourself you can't you can't pick up
oh i'd go like go low i could say
but i think men would go eight i really
think of men men would go eight
for themselves yeah
yeah what do you rate yourself one to
ten
i can't use seven
i think i'll choose a six because who i
would rate a ten
i'd rate mark will be jordan at 10.
michael b jordan yeah okay like like a
guy who's a 10 is a guy who has the
status has the success has the he has he
has the looks no i'm just talking about
lux just purely unless that purely looks
if i have ah
i don't know i'll i'll let others be the
judge i'll let others be no it's fine
just pick it i don't know one to ten i
feel like i feel like you have to i feel
like you have to let your results
your results show where you land your
results show yeah
does that make sense yeah so it's all
good someone's saying like oh i'm really
good at trading right but if you haven't
made any money from trading how good are
you okay so based on your results one to
ten what would you rate yourself seven
seven guys i'm not going any lower
this is so funny because um
like
girl oh actually i currently talk about
girls or guys but like you know a lot of
girls will kind of be like oh so if
their ex gets a new girl girls will tend
to be like they're a downgrade to feel
better to yourself fit about themselves
but there was i saw a tick tock and it
was like you don't want your x-man to
downgrade you want if anything
you want him to be like with a hot
person because then you're like this is
his caliber this is his category this is
his like league i would rather be the
ugliest girl a man has dated than be the
best looking girl a man has dated that's
my personal opinion
i've had a few girls come back just as
my career
no no but like no i would i i'm petty in
that i'd rather you quote unquote
downgraded but imagine then being in
that pool and being like oh
you think that i am so
it's horrible to reduce people's numbers
but let's say let's say that we're we're
all sevens and our x's then go on to
date fours you're like you think i'm the
same as a four
oh
you think i would have full i would say
i would say your life got worse after me
baby yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm teddy
no shape no shame in this game that's it
i'm not changing you didn't ask a
question would you would you rate
yourself five would you yeah one to ten
i give myself five
you don't think you don't you don't
think your height adds to your
attractiveness
i think heart's looking different i
would say like one to ten i would say
five maybe six because i think that if
you're an eight to ten you can model i
don't think i could model and my results
have shown that i cannot model so
so i would say five maybe six on a good
day that's what i would give myself okay
but i also think that like like for a
girl this is how i divide it it's like
your body your face is like the starting
point like so for guys this is how i do
it yeah so let's say if a guy was a five
but he was like in the top like twenty
percent of height eight in height right
divided by two you're six point five
or is that a seven i don't know
i don't know what that is for women
for a woman it's like your body
basically it's the same thing it's like
your face plus your body and like i
think men are a lot
like
guys
guys don't forget a lot for an ass let
me tell you oh
i got a lot more attention when my bum
got big and i was like interesting
because i shaved my head clean bald and
i shaved my head clean bored to be
conventionally unattractive and so i was
like i want to be ugly why
um so i wanted to focus on myself and
not date men i was like so if men think
i'm ugly they're not going to come
towards me they're not going to i'm
going to wonder like why like you seem
to just have like a slight disdain for
men when we talk
no like i just wanted to be ugly because
i was like i need to spend time with
myself because i was very co-dependent
on their like appreciation i was very
co-dependent upon them
i think it's okay like to let them gas
you up a little bit yeah like i don't
why is that bad it was all my
self-control that i was like if i if
you're not gonna get it forever when
you're 50. it's not gonna be there i'll
take it now
i feel it was more of an insecurity
selfish i was like if i feel ugly i'm
obviously not gonna try and
communicate with men if i feel ugly and
i feel insecure but unfortunately i felt
amazing when i shaved my head but then
my body got a lot better and so and i
get men all the time so i i did a poem i
was like right should i grow my hair
should i keep it short and majority of
men were like you look better with long
hair yeah beauty standards but then the
men that i know are like you look really
hot and i'm like i don't know because
they're crying
but it's because it's not because of my
hair on my face it's because of my ass
but my ass got so much better and they
were like that is what we're to take up
other question for this is male rating
things he went face in height right yeah
what about his body
um because i play less of a pop
actually i asked a girl this the other
day but she was 6'3 so keep that in mind
my friends are all tall because like i
play volleyball
so my short friends are five five
um let's see i asked her i
for me but also i think tall girls like
value height like we'd rather have like
i could not do someone like a lot
shorter than me like that would not work
um i think like muscles is like a bonus
like i think it probably adds a point
but i think like if you're overweight
like that subtracts like three
yeah
yeah yeah
so would you take how how tall how tall
are you in heels i don't know like six
three
i think the shortest you sure you were
in heels no i don't think two maybe six
i don't know i'm five eleven and a half
i don't know if i feel like you're the
same height i mean in hills
i don't know i feel like i'm 60. would
you i feel like we should yeah who would
you um would you rather would you rather
a guy who is 6'2 by average body
would you rather a guy who is 510 but a
really good question
over the 510 really good body yeah wow
height is i knew height was a thing but
then shorter than me if you said six
foot i might have switched it uh but i
just can't six boy you want like six in
there yeah
six foot yeah like if you said like six
two versus six four i might have picked
body but like like for girls it's like
we don't i don't care like it's just
like my height ish or taller
like once you start getting like
noticeably shorter than me i'm like
doesn't matter how how big that junk is
how many how much of an eight-pack you
got
don't matter
what's that
yeah go ahead go ahead okay um well i
should go um why don't you ask why don't
you ask me a question ask you a question
is that something that we could disagree
on
is there anything that we disagree on i
feel like there must be something is
there something we just have the same
sadistic sense of humor
messaging audio today
um what do we disagree on
[Music]
i don't know you've probably watched
more of my content ouch ouch
you found me first right
you messaged me first
i did i you didn't know but that was
because of ali it was it was okay
uh have you seen anything you disagree
with me on
do you think men have the right to cheat
i think they have the right to cheat you
have to
you have to define what cheating is to
you
is cheating lying or is cheating
exercising options without lying i think
well it would be
do you think that's good for a nuclear
family to have a